we're in it for the long haul and
whoever is president is going to reach
that decision and there there is no
hundred days on Iraq that what will
happen that the new president will
arrive and I expect that the new
president will face some dramatic tests
there that that will be more likely to
be true if it's Hillary Clinton than if
it's John McCain and more likely again
to be true with Barack Obama than
Hillary Clinton but there'll be some
dramatic tests to take the measure of
this person and I think that there one
and that test is as likely to Iraq
arrived in Iraq as anywhere else and I
think that test is going to persuade the
new president that they have to they
don't have the option of winding this
thing up quickly that this is a deep
commitment of the United States with a
lot at stake it looks from the point of
view of the middle of 2008 as if the
trends in Iraq are more positive than
they have been for some time and if that
trend continues and the next president
may be in a position to inherit the
beginnings of a success I mean it'll be
up to that President to continue the
success and make it a success if as that
happens American troops will leave as as
they should have and I think as it would
have been possible for them to leave
under different circumstances a long
time ago and had we you know that
certainly had you said to any just out
anybody was a phone of the war in 2003
do you think American troops will be
there or how many American troops leave
we think be there in 2008 probably the
you the gases would have covered the
range anywhere from 15,000 to 40,000 I
don't think anybody would have imagined
then that it would be the numbers into
there today
the highest estimate I've heard for the
cost of the Iraq war comes from an
economist named Joseph Stiglitz
and he says if you add up all the costs
plus the future medical and then add to
that all the future medical costs of the
people who are wounded and then add the
interest on top of that you can reach us
a figure almost as high as a trillion
dollars that's an astonishing amount of
money it's 114th the best estimate of
the cost of the president's prescription
drug program so when you I mean these
numbers are very very big but when
you're trying to compare magnitudes
understand that that decision to proceed
with prescription drug in 2004 was 14
times probably as costly as Iraq whether
you like the Iraq decision or not it's
not what is Iraq is not the heaviest
burden on the finances of the United
States the failure to finance properly
the pending retirement of the baby boom
just divorce